good morning believe nation if you're
thinking about whether to continue
following your dream or if it's time to
move on to plan B I'm going to share
with you an inspiring clip from Chris
Gardner that I think will help you gotta
have a plan everybody's got a dream
everybody's got a goal what's the plan
and your plan has got to have something
I call the c5 complex your plan has got
to be clear concise compelling
consistent and committed you've got to
have a plan and when you're trying to do
something that you are truly passionate
about there is no plan B okay Plan B
sucks alright okay so it's as simple as
that you got to have a plan I mean think
about that for a second mm-hmm three
examples Michael Jordan won six NBA
championships with the Chicago Bulls
because he was committed to plan a not
plan B Oprah Winfrey became the queen of
all media because she was committed to
plan a not Plan B whatever your politics
are Barack Obama is sitting in the White
House because he was committed to plan a
not Plan B okay Plan B sucks I love that
clip Plan B's sucks and I got nothing
else to add to that one so I want to
hear from you does Plan B suck leave it
in the comments below I want to hear
from you thank you for watching continue
to believe and I'll see you again s'more
morning for another shot of espresso to
start your day